seven feet bearing strange fruits  Heavenly Father we come to thank you for  your word and your will blood on the  leaves and blood at the roof you listen  to him and you might just make it into  heaven black bodies swinging in the  South breeze submit yourselves to your  masters the whole respect strange fruit  hanging from the poplar trees brethren I  pray you see I lose some sing praise in  the Assembly of the righteous let the  Saints be joyful in glory but the high  praise to God feel the mouths of the  Saints and a two-edged sword in the hand  to execute vengeance from the demonic  nations punishments on those peoples the  blind and Kings will change things  praise the Lord  everyone in the city gets a shot at  being a star live on my stage